[Music]
[Applause]
wedged between europe north africa and
central asia the middle east is
undoubtedly one of the hottest spots in
international geopolitics whether we're
talking about energy supply religion
terrorism opaque finances or wars the
middle east is always in the limelight
we are talking about a place that is
geographically as close to the west as
it is socially politically and
culturally distant
however within this agitated region
there is a surprisingly stable group of
countries with a shared goal to steer
the destinies of the islamic world a
common goal but with very different
methods specifically we can find two
large groups saudi arabia and the united
arab emirates on the one side and qatar
and turkey on the other
and visualpolitik fans the qatar turkey
alliance is precisely the latest great
alliance the latest great aung taunt to
be forged in this troubled region of the
world and take note because apart from
iran the rivalry between these two major
groups is so great that we could almost
almost call it a real conflict a sort of
arab cold war for example the savage
boycott with which the emirates and the
arab nations punished qatar between 2017
and 19 was perhaps the most prominent
example but by no means the only action
in this particular arab game of thrones
so what exactly is the alliance between
turkey and qatar based on what interests
are they pursuing and perhaps the most
important question of all what on earth
distances them from the two largest
monarchies in the persian gulf you want
to know more let's get cracking
[Music]
as it stands the islamic world is as
complex as is possible to be perhaps
sometimes even incomprehensible to those
of us who are not part of it but if we
try to simplify the political map we
could say that there are as you all know
two main religious branches shiism which
is mainly concentrated in iran and
sunnism which is basically the
prevailing religion in the rest of the
muslim world well if we look closer and
focus on the middle east from the sunni
side we find two large political
religious blocs what we could call the
islamist bloc and the block of
absolutist monarchies and then between
there are some countries that play both
sides and of course different insurgent
groups on either side
[Music]
the islamist bloc is led primarily by
qatar and turkey and the political
insurgent faction that these countries
finance promote and help in every
conceivable way possible is known as the
muslim brotherhood an organization that
plays a key role in this whole story
then on the other hand the group of
absolutist monarchies is led by saudi
arabia and the united arab emirates
although bahrain is often included and
by affiliation and alliance so is egypt
these are the two alliances that are
currently splitting our politics right
down the middle now what exactly does
each group stand for what is pitting
them against each other and let's be
honest another important question why
should we even care
well you see on the one hand islamism or
political islam is a theory that
supports a kind of islamic democracy as
an essential political system its
greatest exponent is the muslim
brotherhood a supernational and
ultra-conservative organization that
former president donald trump himself
has to be considered as a terrorist
group well the muslim brotherhood is
mainly financed by qatar and helped by
turkey then in turn this organization
finances advise and collaborates with
israel's parties in much of the muslim
world their objective is to implement
sharia law and their particular vision
of civil political islamism which in
practice clashes with the regimes of
countries like saudi arabia of course
we're talking about a very very unusual
model of democracy one in which politics
and the state have the mission of
imposing a religious interpretation of
life laws and institutions in fact one
of the problems it presents is the
direct influence of imams and in many
cases very radical imams
in contrast to this is the theory of
saudi arabia and the united arab
emirates whose political system is based
on a royal family that is supposed to be
able to keep religious radicalism under
control and that is exactly what
muhammad bin sayed crown prince of abu
dhabi and de facto ruler of the united
arab emirates is defending tooth and
nail he's probably the most powerful
arab leader in the world right now
well the fact is that according to bin
zayed arab society today is not ready
for democracy to the extent that
openness to the world could only be led
by authoritarian regimes in this way
according to this political leader
promoting democracies would only feed
fundamentalist groups that would end up
winning elections of course as you can
imagine both the uae and saudi arabian
governments are better enemies of the
muslim brotherhood and not only that as
the qatari and turkish bloc shelters and
protects this political islamist
organization friction conflicts and
tense situations between the two blocks
are the order of the day and you know
what this is exactly where this whole
story gets interesting check this out
an alliance to control them all
[Music]
at this point in the video i think
there's a question we're probably all
wondering where on earth does the
friendship between two countries as
geographically distant as turkey and
qatar come from what interests do they
have in each other well it must be said
that this link began much earlier than
we might think specifically at the end
of the 19th century at that time qatar
became part of the ottoman empire but of
course the current alliance has nothing
actually to do with that
the close turkish qatari link took a
giant leap when in 2002 the justice and
development party came to power in
turkey this is an islamist party with a
vision quite different from the secular
turkey that ataturk founded so as you
can imagine the impression that this
party had on muslim brotherhood was
quite positive and in fact since then
the ties between the two organizations
have become closer and closer
[Music]
[Applause]
and at this point i ask you another
question who do you think is the main
sponsor financier and promoter of the
muslim brotherhood
qatar
but be careful because this issue let's
call it political or ideological is not
the only one that has conquered the
turks next we have to reckon with
erdogan's own ambition because that's no
secret the turkish leader's fantasy is
to turn turkey into the major sunni
power in the muslim world a position
that is currently shared between saudi
arabia and the united arab emirates a
post a position for which turkey needs
to extend its tentacles particularly in
the persian gulf and that happens only
and exclusively through qatar the
rebellious black sheep of the arabian
peninsula and of course some of you may
be thinking but how is this possible if
turkey and erdogan wanted to join the
european union even mariano rajoy the
former president of spain once crashed a
rally in favour of erdogan
rajoy ends up at a rally of erdogan's
islamist party after inaugurating a
subway line in ankara so how on earth
can it want to become the great sunni
power of the muslim world and at the
same time want to be a part of the most
influential supernational organization
in the west well this is where we get
into the two-phased game that erawan has
played and to some extent continues to
play practically since the moment he
came to power in 2003
[Music]
at that time both turkey and qatar
managed to portray an image to the west
of two examples of models of
modernization and openness in the muslim
world turkey was considered by europeans
to be the living proof that a country
with a muslim majority could become a
genuine consolidated democracy this gave
an important international role for
example it became the mediator of some
of the most serious conflicts in this
part of the world then for its part
qatar became the main connection the
main bridge between the west and some
radical islamist insurgent groups as
well as tyrannical governments of all
kings for example qatar participated in
mediations between hamas fatah and the
state of israel between saddam hussein
and the united states and between
lebanon and hezbollah among many other
groups
[Music]
and this is exactly how doha became the
diplomatic capital of the middle east
and the arab world the last outstanding
example was precisely the negotiation
between the trump administration and the
taliban in which the u.s withdrawal from
afghanistan was agreed everything was
going smoothly and at full throttle so
much so that under such circumstances
turkey and qatar seemed almost textbook
on the one hand turkey was gaining
influence on political clout thanks to
guitar while qatar was gaining the
protection of a nato member and military
giant and it is right here that we have
to make a small digression qatar has
always lived under the paranoia that any
day that could be invaded by the saudis
because let's face it relations between
these two countries have traditionally
been atrocious
there was even what has become known as
the qatari saudi proxy war a kind of
cold war or latent conflict in which
each country used third parties to do
each other's dirty work we were talking
about terrorist gangs political parties
and religious movements that were in
charge of the dirty work but of course
qatar is much much smaller so there was
always the fear that one day saudi
arabia would send its army to occupy the
emirate and precisely to avoid that
qatar needed an ideological ally that
was large relatively rich and militarily
strong
enter turkey
[Music]
[Applause]
gradually qatar and turkey managed to
position themselves as a kind of arbiter
among certain sectors of the muslim
world and in 2011 they wanted to take a
step further to play a much more active
role in islamic geopolitics it was then
when they began to invest millions and
millions of dollars to support all kinds
of insurgent movements revolutionary
groups and even groups considered as
terrorists by a large part of the
international community all with the aim
of bringing down governments and
replacing them with islamist parties
loyal to the muslim brotherhood we are
talking about groups such as hezbollah
and hamas among others
any bets on what the outcome of all of
this was exactly it was the arab spring
the arab spring was a series of revolts
that spread throughout the arab world
and were interpreted in the west as a
popular uprising against despotic and
corrupt rulers however everything
indicates that these revolts were
promoted and financed by qatar and
turkey and in fact they used so many
resources and the success was so great
that suddenly the governments of saudi
arabia and the united arab emirates
began to be seriously worried would they
be next to suffer the consequences this
is exactly how the two persian gulf
monarchies joined shortly afterwards by
bahrain and egypt formed a four-way
alliance known as the middle east
quartet
of course this quartet declared qatar
and turkey a threat both to regional
politics and to its own interests from
that moment on qatar became more and
more isolated from its neighbours and
also increasingly threatened making it
more and more dependent on turkey and
then on the turkish side do you remember
the coup attempt of 2016 well it's still
not clear who orchestrated it
self-imposed coup or international coup
but many fingers point to the theory
that it was backed by the united arab
emirates with the aim of overthrowing
erdogan
middle eastern supporters of turkey's
failed coup a year on the uae and
egypt's involvement in turkey's failed
cub attempt is more apparent than ever
before and although all this fuss may
seem in practice to be a diplomatic and
political failure the truth is that
turkey got what it wanted to counteract
the great arab petrol monarchies and
achieve a prominent political and even
military presence in the persian gulf
the fact is that this situation created
such immense tension that the events did
not take long to unfold and what
happened happened
five arab nations moved to isolate qatar
putting the us in a bind
our powers list 59 individuals as qatar
linked terrorism supporters we've
covered the blockade in a couple of
videos here on visualpolitik already
videos in which we've already told you
how far from making qatar change the
blockade served no other purpose but to
unite the emirate of the al-thani family
with turkey with turkey and also with
another arch enemy of saudi arabia
qatar restores full relations with iran
deepening gulf feud obviously yes qatar
suffered economically from the blockade
of its neighbors but we are also talking
about countries so damned rich that as a
leading qatari banker said this would
only mean that they would have to go
from five servants to three the fact is
that although the blockade is now a
thing of the past the tensions between
the two blocks continue but at this
point what if we put aside the political
and strategic aspects and focus a little
bit more on the numbers on the economic
part what has this whole story meant in
terms of money and pay attention because
this is important
[Music]
every favor comes at a price
the economic relations between turkey
and qatar have increased since the
alliance was launched in 2002 but
perhaps not in the way you may be
thinking interestingly turkey's trade
with saudi arabia and the emirates has
grown more than with guitar
i guess size does actually count here of
course that's not the whole story
qatar and turkey have signed significant
agreements on tourism investment and
defense especially in defence where
important arms contracts have been
sealed in addition qatar has not
hesitated for a moment to provide
enormous economic support to its ally
during the crisis that both the turkish
economy and the lira itself have been
weathering since 2018
to give you an idea of the magnitude of
what we are talking about between 2018
and the end of 2019 qatar has
contributed about 20 billion dollars to
rescue the turkish economy and that's
not all in mid-2020 in the midst of the
coronavirus pandemic qatar signed a 15
billion currency swap agreement with
turkey to resuscitate the finances of
the erdogan government
[Music]
in practice many experts suggest that
this economic assistance is nothing more
than a kind of compensation for the
increasing protection that turkey is
giving to qatar and wait because there
is
[Music]
more in economic military terms since
2017 qatar has finalized the purchase of
numerous pieces of turkish military
equipment and not only that the qataris
have also granted loans to turkey's
military industry and have invested 100
million dollars in bmc one of turkey's
leading armored vehicle manufacturers
this is how qatar the third largest arms
reporter in the world in recent years
has become a major customer of the
turkish military industry a precious
support at a very difficult time for the
turkish economy and companies
[Music]
some would even say that it's a
lifesaver by the way before finishing
there is one thing we cannot forget
within the umbrella of protection turkey
has opened its own military base in doha
the capital of qatar a facility designed
to house a permanent contingent of 5 000
soldiers so you see this is the great
alliance that's been born in the middle
east an alliance that at all levels
seems to be here to stay but having said
that it's your turn could there be an
open military conflict between turkey
and the two great arab powers of the
persian gulf saudi arabia and the
emirates will qatar continue to support
groups like the muslim brotherhood leave
us your answer below in the comments we
hope that now you can better understand
the political situation in the middle
east and if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe and remember if you want to
check us out you can always do our with
our new videos every week and you can
contribute to help us making this kind
of content in the future you can check
us out our patreon below we'll leave
your link in the description once again
thanks for being with us all the best
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you